فرقت القوى الامنيه اعتصاما
العسكريين المتقاعدين وبعض مجموعات ما
يعرف في العراق
والمعارضين للسلطه السياسيه حاليا في
لبنان اطلقت القوى الامنيه وبلا من
قنابل المسيله للدموع وتواصل الاشتباك بين
المعتصمين وهذه القوه الامنيه المولجه
بحمايه رئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه والمجلس
النيابي
وصل المعتصمون رشقه القوى الامنيه
بالحجاره فيما ردت القوى الامنيه باطلاق
المزيد من
القنابل المسيله للدموع ويمكن ايضا علينا
الخروج من هذا المكان
وهذه هي حاليا ساحه المواجهه الحقيقيه بين
القوى الامنيه
المتظاهرين الذين عمدوا خلال ربما الدقائق
الاولى لهذا الاعتصام في وحاولوا الدخول
الى المنطقه القريبه من السرايا الحكومي
واجتبقوا مع الاجهزه الامنيه ثم
اطلقت
القوه الامنيه
الغاز المثير للدموع يطالب هؤلاء بتصحيح
يطالب هؤلاء بتصحيح الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والماليه خصوصا بعد انهيار قيمه العمله
اللبنانيه في لبنان وتاكل اجورهم خصوصا
المتقاعدين والموظفين الذين يتقادون
رواتبهم بالليره بالليره اللبنانيه تفرق
المعتصمون في هذا الاتجاه وعمد اخرون الى
البقاء في الساحه في ساحه المواجهه
وفضلوا ايصال رساله عنيفه للسلطه السياسيه
كما يقولون لاتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لو
قف هذا التدهور المالي والاقتصادي في
لبنان ايهاب العقد الجزيره بيروت